hey guys welcome to an ask ij i don't
know how else to start my videos by
saying hey guys
ow
first of all thank you guys so much for
all of your questions on twitter it's
kind of crazy because every time we do
an ask ij it immediately trends within
seconds you guys are awesome let's get
into our questions shall we my first
question is from camilla who wants to
know from ever coming to norway again i
had the best time in norway so if there
were any events coming up in the next
whenever let me know because i'm gonna
try to go gary wants to know if i've
ever been to the first starbucks in
seattle and as a matter of fact yes i
have been and it's kind of crazy because
the first starbucks is actually not the
first starbucks it was originally in one
location and they moved it down the
street so it's kind of deceiving it's
not the first but it's the first it was
also a little underwhelming it looks
basically just like an old starbucks
addison wants to know if i've ever
played the kim kardashian game
no
i have not i also plan on never playing
it when will you make another music
video well jamie it just so happens that
i made a shark week parody so if you
guys missed this video please go check
it out also be sure to watch the behind
the scenes which is equally as
ridiculous my sister jenna is pouring
fake blood on me in the middle of venice
beach mothers were taking their small
children away from this crime scene and
it looked like a bloodbath i mean there
was legit just blood just all over me
cup songaholic do you like the cup song
wants to know let's show what i love to
be on that's on tv right now i'm pretty
sure yeah they did they canceled it the
cancelled revolution i have i just loved
that show i loved everything about it i
kind of loved that concept of just
having the entire world just basically
just shut down did they they did cancel
it i don't even know what happened at
the end i don't think they didn't even
get to the end they even finished the
show i'm hoping there's still a few more
episodes that i haven't seen because
right now i have no closure i need
revolution closure i also would have
loved to have been on fringe oh my god i
love that show anyway i love jj abrams
basically it's my dream to be in
something that jj abrams does i
love him the minecraft girl is wondering
if i have a woman crush i do actually
i've got a bunch of them this particular
woman crush i got to meet at the teen
choice awards and i kind of was like
i love you she was so pretty and so nice
and and um yeah i love hillary duff is
your hairy always that flowy and
blumptuous i don't think voluptuous is a
word i also think you're asking about my
hair you know i don't know i'm not sure
if you guys can tell but my hair is a
little bit lighter lately
and i haven't been curling it because
when i curl it and it's lighter i kind
of look like a freaking barbie doll and
i don't like it
james mayo is asking if i would rather
be a pig or a shark for a day yeah i'm
gonna go with a shark because i would
just like eat everything i would be a
pig essentially in the sense that i was
eating everything like a pig i'd like
some i would probably bite a human just
to see what it was like nicolas wants to
know where you can get the so-so happy
jumpers you live in scotland it's
actually a really good question i'm not
sure if they have international shipping
or not i think they do you guys haven't
seen it we released the new i just seen
so so happy hoodie for 2014. it's this
awesome pink fun just festive hoodie i
love it i think it would look great on a
guy as well maybe you might not agree if
you're a dude but i think it would the
best part is if you think you can pull
it off you can so guys don't be scared i
think it would look quite fabulous on
you where'd that accent come from i'm
beginning to think that i might have a
multiple personality disorder i start
talking in an accent i blame libby it's
her fault maybe i am libby maybe i'm a
justine maybe i'm samantha maybe i'm
crazy in your snapchats how do you add
the extra text design like beverly hills
in the corner so if you guys don't
follow me on snapchat you definitely
should i'm ijustine it's just i justine
snapchat has geolocation filters now so
if you slide over depending upon your
location and where you are if you're at
an event or if snapchat has them enabled
for whatever location you're at you'll
be able to have these fun filters and
again it is all location based so you
may walk five feet this way and that
filter is not available i really really
really like snapchat and i think they're
doing a good job at whatever they're
doing so it looks like we're at the end
of our questions so thank you guys for
watching i love you um subscribe and
like and whatever
whatever do whatever you want to do i'll
see you guys later bye but there was
like a dude who got eaten here no that
was my hat that's what yeah man she was
for sure
100 we're perfectly fine can we have
shark week for the rest of our lives